new hair who does how do you know that
you're making a fashion statement and
not creating a question got to go with
it if you love me you got to stand by it
and not worry about it
yes that's Mila Kunis rocking a bold new
do while out and about in Los Angeles
it appears the actress has treated in
her brunette locks for a new blonde -
with turquoise tips and the change is
definitely recent as Mila was just
spotted at a Los Angeles Dodgers game
over the weekend with hubby Ashton
Kutcher and her classic brown locks I
mean here's the truth I have an amazing
stylist the mom of two has been known to
rock different hairstyles over the years
but she's always maintained her glossy
Brown strand which makes us think the
lighter hue might be for a new role it
wouldn't be the first time Kunis went
blonde in 2017 the actress sported a
blonde wig for her role in the spy who
dumped me and based on what she and
co-star kate mckinnon told et at the
premiere it definitely sounds like
blondes have more fun please tell me
that you guys really are friends now and
that this relationship is going to
continue it is real I'm sorry what you
see is real unfortunately I can't touch
her professional faith and she's not
mr. hours hours hours of work that's the
word that we didn't do we know the suit
[Music]